we're willing to bet most of you know
zoe saldana as the green-skinned
universe saving gomorrah from guardians
of the galaxy but you probably don't
know about Sal Donna's story passed long
before she became a staple in the Marvel
Cinematic Universe she was on a
trajectory toward superstardom dancing
in the Dominican Republic born in 1978
Zoey Yadira Saldana Nazario was hit with
tragedy at a young age her father a
radio Saldana died in a car accident
with Saldana was just nine years old
after spending her childhood in Jackson
Heights Saldana was uprooted and
relocated to the Dominican Republic
following her father's passing with her
mother and her sisters Sicily and Mariel
Feld on a settle into her new life and
discovered her love of dance and
especially ballet after a while however
felt Ana's passion for dance faded in
the 2012 debut issue of Cosmopolitan for
Latinas magazine Saldana dished on why
she ditched the dancing dreams saying
quote I had to quit ballet because it
felt like a part of me was dying inside
it takes a lot of courage to face up to
things you can't do because we feed
ourselves so much denial end quote
the relentless full-body immersion in
ballet such a physical fall as well and
she soon realized she quote didn't have
the feet for ballet Saldana gave up the
dream but better things were on the
horizon back to the Big Apple
in 1995 the Saldana family packed their
bags and returned home to New York where
Saldana started working with the New
York Youth Theatre starring in a
production of Joseph and the Amazing
Technicolor Dreamcoat her performance
landed her an agent who helped her snag
a guest role in everyone's favorite
murder show law and order Saldana popped
up into 1999 episodes
merger and refuge part two though she
went uncredited for her first appearance
her next gig made her someone to watch
center stage
Saldana broke through to the mainstream
in a big way starring in the teen drama
center stage a film coincidentally
enough all about ballet as the wickedly
talented butts our tongues student Ivana
Ava Rodriguez fell Donna showed off her
expert dance technique and stellar
acting job
so it opened to mostly mediocre reviews
Abel was the role that served as a
launch pad for sell Jonah's career spell
Dada herself has even noted that valet
trained her for actions which she need
for what came next mega stars Saldana
was up for increasingly prominent roles
in britney Spears's 2002 coming-of-age
roadtrip drama crossroads Saldana heard
wedding bells as the bride to be kissed
just ten months later she went back to
her dancing roots again to play Layla
the mysterious love interest is a
musical dramedy drum line but Saldana
wasn't just banking on ballet and beauty
she soon scored a lead in what became
one of Disney's biggest movie franchises
to date Pirates of the Caribbean cells
on a stepped into the swashbuckling
pirates of the carribean the curse of
the Black Pearl to play Anna Maria
a victim of Jack Sparrow's thieving ways
so the role saw her brush shoulders with
high-powered co-stars and offered her
the chance to work with acclaimed
director gore verbinski it was the one
that nearly ruined her relationship with
acting forever during her time on set
she learned her worth as a female in the
business speaking with The Hollywood
Reporter Saldana explained that
unpleasantries behind the scenes were
enough to tempt her to quit acting for
good saying close it was very elitist I
almost quit the business I was 23 years
old and I was like this I am never
putting myself in this situation again
people disrespecting me because they
look at my number on a call sheet and I
think that I'm not important [ __ ] you
and clip star trek stardom following a
string of rom-coms like the heart
specialists and after sex cells on a
board of the enterprise in 2009 and JJ
Abrams Star Trek reboot Abrams himself
asked Aldana to join the project and
after he complimented her abilities she
was sold while not exactly a Trekkie
herself having never seen the 60 show
cells on a portrayed Star Trek fanatics
in both the terminal and get to sell
Donna's mom however is a huge fan of
Star Trek and would often call Saldana
on set to give her advice on how to
approach the character telling MTV quote
she'd be like Zoe so for this scene when
you're in front of Spock's Allura has to
be stoic because she is elegance and
remember she's a translator so she is
there
sociable okay she would leave these
messages and I was like who is this lady
she's such a sci-fi geek and clothes
also in 2009 fell Donna's role in the
James Cameron award-winning sci-fi epic
avatar raised her profile to a new level
the film shattered Cameron's own 12-year
record for the highest-grossing film in
history dethroning site anacs but it
wasn't a paycheck gig for Saldana she
told The Hollywood Reporter
well you just gravitate naturally to
what your heart yearns for I grew up in
a very science-fiction driven household
it was odd for me to grow up and go out
in the world and not see other women
going crazy for science fiction and
quote going green Sal Donna's most
recent scene-stealing role is at
guardians of the galaxy's badass galaxy
saving gal Gamora director James Gunn
approached her about playing the
green-skinned heroine but her sister had
to get her up to speed on who the
characters even worse
Saldana admitted to MTV quote my sister
sort of informed me of it I read the
script and I was blown away with it and
quotes but she also had concerns about
the role during screen tests Saldana
stress Gamora stayed pretty to draw
teenage boys into seeing the film
Saldana explained in an interview with
Collider well I don't know why I was
stressing this a lot but I really was
when we were testing unlike pretty
teenage boys please we got to get their
vote and quote in retrospect her
concerns seemed fairly unfounded the
superhero adventure nabbed the approval
of millions of adoring fans not just
adolescent guys and being a part of the
Guardians is something Saldana truly
cherishes saying plus we're kind of like
the rolling stones of the whole Marvel
comics that I find so appealing
we're like the ones who always fail in
class but for some reason we can burn
the house down and I like that and close
thanks for watching click the looper
icon to subscribe to our YouTube channel
plus check out all this cool stuff we
know you'll love to
you
[Music]